in the movie Ex Machina a programmer  named Caleb wins a contest for a  one-week visit to the home of his CEO to  perform a modern version of the Turing  test basically to test if an AI can pass  off as a human the entire movie takes  place in this one house but through the  Strategic use of glass they're able to  create drastically different  environments upstairs where the CEO  lives you have floor-to-ceiling glass  which opens up to this expansive nature  with views to the lake and the mountains  and downstairs where the experiments  take place the glass is used to contain  and monitor the AI creating an  environment of surveillance there's a  small window to this very manicured  landscape and scenes like this create  confusion as to who's the experiment and  who's the experimenter this actually  hints to the very dark conclusion of the  movie